Je dois m'habituer à ne pas avoir de
voix de contrôle pour le faire éclater ouais crimes maintenant
oui je vous remercie et deux rendez-vous
ça ira le jour où nous sortons depuis
une demi-minute jusqu'à présent ouais j'allais le
faire incliner je  je ne veux pas
gâcher autant nous allons adapter les finances de la maison d'
accord d'
accord nous pouvons le faire un peu plus
loin une bannière un peu plus lente
ok je vais encore incliner vers le bas et ensuite
nous sommes un peu plus bas  est-ce que le feu est
assez long, puis prend une heure, c'est
un peu juste là, je suis
passé, d'accord, d'accord, d'accord, pourrions-nous avoir
des trucs comme regarder en bas,
puis ça monte et peut-être révéler
quelque chose sur l'eau  ce serait un
peu court tout le long de votre
pantalon océan ensemble de compétences sur ce
fond va caresser comme un fou
oui ok est-ce que ça envoie tout regarder
comment était l'ulster était-ce agréable
transition
jouer
Oh
c'est une province plurielle
appelez-moi
prenez votre parent  ok ouais je pense que je
pense que tu m'as fait exploser et c'est un faible
rappelez-vous le  le nom des gars
nous sommes là c'est ce que nous sommes donc nous avions l'habitude
de porter là-bas avant avec vous les gars
lit pilote la même entreprise
maintenant nous allons
wow regardez ça
comme ça vous voyez la route
c'est super dur aussi loin que comme  obtenir
des ins et des choses comme ça à faire comme
une main vers le bas ou incliner
comme une palpation d'accord les
garçons vous filmez une maison la
maison comme une glissade d'accord par exemple si
nous fumons ouais mais comme toute la
fumée  la fam est-ce que tu vas jamais
j'aime le ciel ou nous pourrions monter ce gars
aussi
voir cette nouvelle usine ou cadre mais tu as dit
là ouais nous le gardons là-bas le
Sénat Oh priez ouais soyez un gros spot de surf la
nuit dernière personne ne l'a dit  nous n'importe quoi ouais
ouais ils sont un peu nerveux à propos de ça que
j'ai vraiment couvert et nous avons fait un côté oh
mon dieu quoi d'autre s Idol je ouais vice les
pilotes ont appelé un let's truck oh ouais Oh
Lance Armstrong c'est comme ton père
ok je termine ça ils  juste monter je suppose que
descendre à l'eau peut être comme ouais la
naissance
est votre gagnant chopra je l'ai aussi mis un  Toute la
nuit
après avoir terminé, je peux vous faire la même
chose avec juste un peu plus
lentement d'accord et obtenir un peu de guerre ou de l'
océan,
nous avons une couche de nuages qui tombe après d'ac
ord, finissez-le donc je dis oui en part
culier
l'avancée du ciel pour être
moi
aussi maintenant